oh those those days on the road had to
be crazy oh man a blur man i bet yeah
our [ __ ] was like well you know the one
the one good thing about me that
balanced me out is i had a record out
before d12
called attack of the widows so
at least i i did get that underground
experience
i i struggled
i did all the shot i went to new york
it was [ __ ] nowhere to stay slept in
cars eight dollar slice pieces
struggled 90s and underground rap life
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i did that [ __ ] so you know so when
we signed with marshall i mean it was
just like
boom instant you know you already kind
of like i'm used to this [ __ ] anything
that yeah but we got hotels we good some
a couple of guys hadn't
experienced that they went straight from
to private jets you and proof like the
most experienced in the group prior i
mean outside of england yeah yeah yeah
yeah proof proof was uh
signed to this label called
mari uh maurice malone the clothing is
out he was signing i remember maurice
malone yeah for closing the brain yeah
proof was signed to him
and uh i was signed a federation record
shout out to rico oh wow and uh yeah so
we we was pretty seasoned
but you know
so uh we had that underground experience
but
you know when we signed a shady man it
was straight private jets
was the formation of d12 prior to eminem
being in the group or was it something
that happened
like at the same time
no d12 happened before
eminem uh you know yeah eminem was in
the group
from the beginning it was six of us
you know what i'm saying and but no it
was supposed to be twelve of us my bad
probably twelve
but we never could find 12 members to
stick with us
so you know there's a lot of ways to
come yeah yeah that's a lot of people
right yeah so
yeah so we made six rappers with two
personalities
i actually like that yeah everybody's
got two personalities yeah 12 people 30
dozen yep there you go there it is and
it and uh
it was the redundant but uh a rock band
out of um maryland had the name oh
d12 is dope though so we had to change
it to d12 yeah was there anybody uh who
we may know of of any notoriety from the
detroit area that almost made the group
but didn't
that was i almost was in d12 yeah you
know he was in it for a minute but you
know
he you know i didn't know that
going off doing his own thing i don't
even think he ever came to session but
he he definitely was what's down with us
damn i might be mine if i else if i'm
lying please don't strike me down man
you know if elsa
elsa and eminem going back and forth on
records would have been oh yeah
oh yeah and he ended up in slum village
yeah
that was crazy too yeah
yeah because he he ended up in like a
what was that like the third version of
slum village
so many moving parts yeah it was a lot
man yeah it was hard to keep up with to
be honest yeah yeah it was a lot going
on yeah